I really honestly do this for you guys I
really do you guys owe me instead of
sleeping I do the list number one take
Emily to school I am just so jealous you
get some looking nice and today we just
from around at the park I don't know how
she doesn't start Sarah Jessica Parker
Greg Kinnear Pierce Brosnan and
Christina Hendricks the plot is we have
surgical partners she's a businesswoman
struggling with her business trying to
get ahead in her career lots of pressure
there he's also married has kids lots of
pressure there lots of pressure
basically and she's trying to succeed
that's essentially the plot of the film
as a lot of different things to handle
and no one knows how she does it and
here's all I have to say well actually I
have a lot to say but here's the first
thing I want to say I don't know how she
does it
is a perfect title and a perfect thought
in my head when I think of Sarah Jessica
Parker's entire career I don't know how
she does it
she's constantly in these films you know
and they're all the movies she's been in
are essentially elongated episodes of
Sex in the City I mean she even narrates
this movie just like in the television
show it is it's an elongated episode of
Sex in the City
kindergarten bake sale Christmas lights
birthday party I don't know how you do
it I don't know how you do it I don't
know how she does it all those children
I have to so impressive you yeah
but two minor twins
this film is charmless it's boring it
doesn't have any went to it all the
characters that are supposed to have
chemistry they just laugh and giggle and
smile at each other there's no chemistry
there's no real chemistry because the
things of these people are saying from
this script don't seem real doesn't seem
like anything a human would actually say
to each other there are funny things
about the film they tried to go in a
different direction in some ways like
one of the things we're doing is like
this shut office like style thing where
throughout the film they show the
characters just standing and talking to
the camera as if they're being
interviewed and there
a little bit of cleverness about at
first but then they kept doing it all
the way through the whole film and they
did it with certain characters like they
do with this one blonde woman who is
literally introduced in one scene in the
beginning of the film you never learn
anything about her at all just
everything you learned about her is from
that one scene then throughout the rest
of the movie they keep cutting back to
her and she's talking giving her opinion
of things you don't care about her you
know nothing about her character in fact
they probably cut to her more than they
do the only funny character in this
movie which is served as the Parkers
assistant her name is like Momo or
something and she's literally the only
funny person in this whole movie
Jackie Lambert our New York office has
bark to a proposal to end he'd like to
beat the offer
go ahead deal if there's anything else
you need to adjust
I like Pierce Brosnan as an actor he's
got nothing to do here he was great in
the ghostwriter
I liked him as bond he's got nothing to
do here at all Sarah Jessica Parker is
the exact same as she always is exact
same literally Greg Kinnear I also like
once again
he's just playing the guy who's you know
like the doting father trying to take
care of things and it's just so poorly
written that you really don't care at
all about any of these characters I know
this film isn't aimed at my demographic
at all I'm a young man
this film is aimed at you know maybe
like middle-aged women and so there'd be
less things that I can appreciate about
this movie or understand or relate to
however I can understand and relate to
human beings and I know that human
beings don't talk like this
they don't talk like this at all the
script is so Hollywood I love my work
although sometimes I wish I didn't love
it so much you're allowed to miss your
children
I need somebody down there tonight
I can't go on like this you think about
not having to worry about priorities all
the time just one of those movies that
like films like 500 days of summer make
fun of where everything is beautiful and
people come together in the snow is
suddenly starts to follow it's all
beautiful and romantic and it doesn't
happen like that in real life I really
can't find much good to say about this
movie except for the fact that it tried
to go different places in the average
romantic comedy and that it wasn't a
awful movie for the first half of the
film I didn't I wasn't bored because I
was like okay we're setting up certain
characters I was okay with it and but I
still you know I wasn't bored by that's
all I can really say however the last
half of the film was exactly like the
first half of the film nothing really
happened except more and more of Sarah's
partner walking around the office things
trying to run and their families bored
and her kids are wondering why she's not
there it's just the same thing all the
way throughout the entire movie so after
a while I was really wanting it to end
me without that job isn't me but also me
without you and then and emily is
nothing this film tries to empower women
a lot and I'm all for that I mean I like
women in fact sometimes I relate to
women even more than I do to guys a lot
of my friends that I can just talk to
our girls and I don't know I mean I'm
just that kind of guy but when I'm
watching the women in this movie they're
like the kind of women that you see
walking and you don't even want to
approach them because you're afraid
they're going to hiss at you and bite
your head off and I don't enjoy 90
minutes with those kind of women in this
film because they're the kind of women
they're just like if you look at them
looks community forward it's like that
those kind of women those aren't the
kind of woman that I follow around with
but I don't know how she does it it's
just it's just not my kind of movie I
don't know if you're a woman you might
enjoy it more than me it's just not my
kind of movie I'm gonna give it a
c-minus
but if you liked my review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stockman
eyes please